here in Pyongyang government officials
are strongly condemning this latest
round of UN Security Council sanctions
using words like evil vicious calling it
a full-scale economic blockade but when
you go out on the streets and speak with
regular people they don't seem concerned
at all it's tough to find a traffic
light in Pyongyang traffic cops direct
the flow of cars the streets noticeably
busier each time I come here busier at
least for now the US says the latest UN
sanctions threatened to cut North
Korea's oil supply by nearly a third
which could spike prices for everything
from taxis to energy a ban on textile
exports and the end of foreign labor
contracts could further slash the income
of this cash starved country but if you
ask Rhee hate young she's not worried
her refreshment stand has a steady flow
of customers
she says life is improving despite round
after round of increasingly heavy
sanctions we have no problems she says
everything I'm selling is made locally
we don't worry we rely on ourselves Kim
hae song casually shrugs off threats
from the United States the US president
Donald Trump said that these sanctions
are just not a big deal and that there's
much worse to come
does that worry you at all we don't care
what the US president says or what the
outside world thinks about us she says
we don't worry because we believe in the
leadership of marshal Kim jong-un keep
in mind this is a very thin slice of
life in this closed country good
reporters like us can only see what the
government allows but all over the North
Korean capital we see plenty of new
construction an increasingly modern
skyline a mandate from North Korea's
leader Kim jong-un determined to prove
he can grow the economy and the nuclear
program all in the face of unprecedented
sanctions for his repeated violations of
international law
you see these posters all over Pyongyang
and they pretty much sum up North
Korea's official response to increase
pressure from the US more missiles North
Korean propaganda is built around their
nuclear program it symbolizes strength
independence it's key to their national
identity is
there anything anything at all that
could get North Korea to walk away from
its nuclear program will never give them
up says reach Hong Sun if we did it
would mean our destruction around town
new posters show a pair of hands ripping
up UN sanctions resolutions North
Korea's defiant message they will never
give up their news even if that means
life is about to get a lot harder and
that really is the bottom line North
Korea says nuclear weapons are vital to
their survival as a nation and they say
these latest UN sanctions will only
speed up not slow their development of
weapons of mass destruction threatening
to escalate an already dangerous
situation even further I'm will Ripley
reporting in Pyongyang North Korea